did you bring anything home with you
from Italy his name was Fabio
no English he was site-specific he
worked really well in Italy but once I
brought him back and realized that he
didn't speak any English he was a little
tough he also had a little problem with
the food
and one day he's like clutching his gut
and he said Julie die and he's like in
Italian he's telling me that he's dying
um because he ate a whole packet of
prosciutto and marscapone
and I'm like for I was in college I
mean I didn't have to shoot a mascarpone
so I go and look in the garbage and
there's an empty package of raw bacon
and an empty tub of cream cheese
left and laughed and picked up the phone
and called the Airlines and you're going
home